[Music]
we brought together seven strangers
Protected Their identities and created a
space for them to be completely honest
what will be revealed when they take the
mask off
everyone
is racist including me
[Music]
I'm not like nobody wants to think of
themselves as racist and I don't think
that I'm racist in the way that I think
we think about racism but I think I took
the question as these like inherent
biases that everybody has and I think
most of the time most people are not
aware of this it's we I think there's
like this new generational divide of
like you are a racist or you said a
racist thing and I don't know where the
line is you might say something a little
racist or something you don't see as
racist someone calls you out and you're
like oh I'm so sorry you know apologize
and if you argue that point against them
then I would say you're a racist but if
you understand you come to understanding
you learn everyone would be able should
be able to forgive that person and be
like no no you were just you made a
mistake people make mistakes I don't
know I feel like it's a binary yeah
because I think a really important thing
that kind of is tough with cancer
culture right now is that Russia to
Redemption and so after you've said
something wrong you know how do you make
yourself right again in the public
sphere at least personally I feel like I
don't see that a lot with cancel culture
is if someone makes amends there's now
an acceptance like hey you did something
wrong but you're okay now or at least
better I think social media kind of
incentivizes against Redemption and I
feel like it's like it's just outrage
and I do think people do like the rush
of anger I I don't think people really
believe in Redemption anymore I kind of
I guess just kind of disagree with the
idea of racism as a binary it kind of
goes back to that like really old meme
where like Skipper says like we did it
Mrs Obama racism is over the idea of a
Redemption is just like all right
they've fixed their racism in the sense
that like I think the Redemption that
our society is calling for is impossible
it's almost like you need to like write
a check every time you make a racism and
like that will upsolve you of your thing
where I think like what we should be
doing is like the idea of growth towards
a better understanding
I have struggled with my sexuality
[Music]
I I felt an attraction of men really
young and I just but I didn't connect to
Gay Culture at all and I was like I'm
either straight or gay it can't be any
it can't be another one so I I very
consciously put myself in the closet and
uh you know I didn't I didn't feel
confidence to like be my own person you
know obviously in high school and slowly
but surely I you know I started to come
out to more people and talk about my
experience and and stuff but people come
out of the closet that's one thing
that's that's the second step the first
step is like really kind of like
acknowledging it and like loving
yourself and that was the hardest part
for me and I'm pretty good now uh I'm
I'm happy happy and bi now very
comfortable with my sexuality and you
know I know it's a spectrum but I I
think I'm most part straight I struggled
with depression for a long time and I
think one of the side effects of that
for me was I fell into an eating
disorder and I got really skinny and
because I was struggling with an eating
disorder it made me for some reason
question my sexuality and I understand
how messed up that is now I started to
ask myself why did you associate that
one with the other and um
I think it was because it's just not
largely talked about with straight men
that people we can still struggle with
mental health and eating disorders I
have a very core memory somebody might
say of me walking in to my house after
the first day of first grade and I'm
just like hey Mom I think I have a crush
on my friend and my mom kind of laughed
and she's like oh boys don't have
crushes on boys
and I was like cool got it awesome uh
just put that in the back of my mind and
I'm still working with like the idea
that if I have a crush on a man that
that's not inherently disgusting because
what's more disgusting than a man
wanting you like you said like
connecting to the gay community unless
you fit like it seems the tiniest of
boxes is really hard and even now like I
went out last night and I
had somebody that I kind of like caught
my eye but I had no idea how to approach
that it's like everybody else got like a
manual and like 17 easy steps to not
have social anxiety when in the club and
I'm just like I guess I was sick that
day I didn't get that class I didn't
sign up for it on uh LinkedIn just sorry
I'm using humor to cover it up I went up
to the guy I said you're so handsome and
I was like oh my God that sounds like
I'm an old woman you know we're like
yeah it's one of those things where it's
like oh obviously don't say that but
it's like okay but then what do you say
yeah because like do I not think that
he's handsome I don't know
have you ever been confused by consent
before
[Music]
there have been instances where you know
in terms of friends relationships
whatever I can go too far because I
misinterpreted consent and just because
people seem comfortable with something
you kind of go along with the I think
the reason I said yes was just thinking
very specifically about a situation you
know situations where both of us have
been
really drunk or something like that
where it's like it's not one person
sober and the other person's drunk and
the drunk person's saying yes but if
you're both drunk and both consenting
and into it in the moment and then the
next day like I've had like a neither of
us really consented is anybody in the
wrong here you know and so that's kind
of what I thought of when I heard I've
been confused about consent it's not as
much in the moment but after the fact in
that scenario Jack that situation is
pretty scary because you interpret it
one way and if someone
was hurt and you didn't mean to do that
and you didn't take the precautions for
that you're still at fault and that
sucks and I'm not saying that's your
situation is like that's the kind of
world we live in where we we can really
get in trouble sometimes even when we
don't mean to hurt others and it sucks
yeah I think that's the whole thing
about consent is it's not always just
like this guy being like Oh Come On Come
On like you know there's such a finer
line it's such there's so many gray
areas that it's really important to have
those conversations because yeah there
can be so many different scenarios that
are still non-consensual so
women have more power than me
[Music]
yeah I definitely don't think women have
more power and I think some people might
think that just because you're seeing a
Grove like growing relative power that
you know some men might not be used to
now that women are kind of getting
closer to being equal to some people
that might feel like they're getting
more power and they might be more
powerful
um and so I can understand why someone
might you know perceive that as relative
but absolutely I don't agree that like
women have more power I think we're
getting closer to equality at this point
where it's a work in progress I don't
know it's like a yes and no question uh
I was uh harassed by a superior uh who
was a woman at a previous job like
repeatedly harassed I've reported it to
my boss who was a white male
and you just laughed it off and said uh
you know toughen up buttercup when women
are harassed I think if I was a woman
and I reported harassment especially
right now with me too and everything
CEO would see a huge red flag a huge
possible controversy and like I know
there's definitely you know ways when
that isn't true but for me it was just
like we don't we don't care you're a man
tough enough I don't give a [__] like
she's a woman she can't harass you and
um
uh
I'm sorry I'm sorry
um uh
and it was really scared and like if I
didn't have some you know good women in
my life and and um some good people
um
I wouldn't have taken action I would
have just toughened up
and I would have let it kill me inside
I'm sorry that happened I'm so sorry not
sorry
I've had fantasies
foreign
[Music]
so I said yes because like I can't think
of a specific time but like I believe I
have at one point it's more
like role-playing under very strict
guidelines and with the understanding
that my partner will stop if I ever get
too uncomfortable in terms of like
fantasizing about actually doing the
very illegal and immoral act no but I
think you know like role-playing or even
like the fiction you read or even like
to a certain extent as long as if we
made uh porn like it's exploring that
healthily I think is valid and it's
something that I think I have done in
the past yeah I kind of agree with that
I like I explore in porn but like
personally no like it it freaks me out
too much you know I do have like this
kind of feel of wanting to be dominated
by a man you know you know or a woman
that's more in porn than like in real
life I I I feel like I'd be freaked out
in real life if that happened but so in
this situation where you're doing this
like with your partner that you stated
are you the person that is receiving
this idea you're saying am I playing the
role of the assailant or the victim yeah
okay the role I am playing would be that
of the assailant do you have seen that
something and my partner would be the
victim due to like social anxiety and
like
just a lot of things that keep me like a
more like docile system as a person
I like exploring a more dominant side
via power dynamics
in a safe environment obviously when
you're assaulted like sexually assaulted
you don't have a choice in the matter
but when you are role playing it you can
say you know like a safe word and that
kind you have the control but when it's
robbed from that controls Rob from you
it you know it messes with you that I
think that's the distinction with the
role play I feel like we kind of have a
misunderstanding here I at least think
that it's really insensitive at least to
be doing these role plays because you
will never be able to feel what these
people feel and like it kind of It kind
of it's off shifting to know that that's
something desired you know I understand
that and like
like I said it is something like
obviously I've never experienced it and
so what I
my fantasy kind of might come from like
a position of privilege and I think
that's why I'd like to
explore it in a healthy way to figure
out like why exactly I feel that way and
I understand like from the outset and
even like as I explained it has a
potential to sound like incredibly like
jarring and the way you're explaining it
the way that's why I'm asking you
questions because I instantly assuming
that you're a person but I know that I
see the way you spoke to me and you know
you obviously have some feelings about
it that you've thought to yourself over
time so like I just want to yeah but and
I think that the way we handled it is
kind of a good way to be communicate
with others and understand issues yeah
no like I appreciate the way you ask the
questions and stuff like that thank you
I have been abused
[Music]
yeah I mean I I've been I just said yes
I've been going through it you go
through it
uh no I think I've just been abused uh
two two ways and abused is such a again
like can mean so many things so I've
been abused emotionally in a
relationship but not physically or
sexually but definitely emotionally and
then I've been abused as like an
employee to to an employer again not
sexually or physically but just
abused their power over me
as I talked about I got harassed by an
older female employee and uh working
through it it's always
it's always a process I don't know
um my family they we've endured
emotional physical abuse from my father
and I'm sure a lot of people kind of you
know a test and see other same things
and he doesn't he lives in a whole
nother country now so I don't really
talk to him and I need that guidance you
know when I'm going from 14 to 18 years
old that's like a really influential
time so it's really hard to have to deal
with that on your own the worst part was
when I told him about some of the issues
I had because I didn't have them to
this is the way he you know hurt me he
kind of just said yo that's your fault
like you can't blame me for that and put
it on me I think this kind of ties into
I want to bring it in how sometimes I
feel like it's a white man I can't
really talk about my problems because
it's you've always been taught to suck
it up I'm sure all of us have been told
that multiple times in your life suck it
up
Buttercup I heard over here one so yeah
for you I remember with your boss
telling you that you know that wasn't
valid and that's not fair I don't think
just because you're a man or white you
can't be abused I was told that growing
up I think abuse
kind of requires a power Dynamic and
like even like all of us were white men
there's always somebody above us there's
a richer whiter man I guess so like what
is exactly the top because there's
always somebody I think above us to
abuse us and that's just not really
talked about
um really quickly I just want to do one
thing there's going to be no talking
it's the last question I have and you
cannot elaborate on your opinion either
way is
the era of white men is over
foreign
[Music]